in 1966 on the Southeastern coast of
Barbados the U.S Army in partnership
with the Canadian government began the
earth-shuttering tests of this massive
artillery gun a 36 meter long barrel
constructed by welding two 16-inch Naval
guns together end to end loaded with
over half a metric ton of black powder
the barrel needed rings of stiffening
reinforcement along its length to
withstand the immense pressure developed
inside long white straightening rods
needed to carefully adjust the barrel to
shoot straight and true its white paint
gave away its true purpose this was no
military gun painted in drab Olive
camouflage this was a scientific
instrument a space cannon a gun capable
of launching a projectile to an altitude
of 180 kilometers nearly halfway to the
orbiting altitude of the International
Space Station and the altitude of the
lowest orbiting satellite ever this gun
was undeniably a space is gone to this
day holding the record for highest
altitude projectile ever launched the
history of this bizarre science project
is a fascinating story from the advances
in ballistic science needed to achieve
this extraordinary Feast to the reasons
Barbados a small island in the Caribbean
was chosen for the gun's location a tale
that ends with bureaucratic sabotage and
the assassination of the lead scientist
this is the story of project harp
thank you
[Music]
the remnants of these experimental guns
remain here on the beaches of Barbados
Lane idle since their final launch in
1966 rusted relics of a bygone era that
you can catch a glimpse of while taking
off from runway09 at grantley Adams
international airport but why here why
on this beach on the Southeastern coast
of Barbados
project tarap was a joint effort from
the Canadian government funding research
at McGill University and the U.S
ballistics research laboratory who are
seeking more data on upper atmosphere
conditions in the same decade the SR-71
made its debut this data was highly
valuable but Gathering that data with
sounding Rockets was expensive
Canada not short and Wide Open Spaces
could have located suitable sites near
their University's hometown of Montreal
however the dean of McGill Donald
mordell had higher Ambitions than just
Gathering upper atmosphere data a vision
of a low-cost space launch system
capable of launching satellites into
orbit for a fraction of the cost
Barbados was selected for these reasons
the most eastern of all the Caribbean
islands firing from the southeastern
shore had a fixed firing angle Over the
Sea there was essentially unlimited
fallout area with plenty of space for
debris from the launches to fall into
the ocean
located along the launch path of Cape
Canaveral the infrastructure needed to
track the launches already existed
nearby and critically located just 13
degrees north of the equator Barbados
would benefit from The increased
rotational speed at the equator and
require lowered launch energies as a
result
Barbados also came with the added
benefit of being a region of extreme
atmospheric research interest the
nursery of hurricanes that surged
through the Gulf of Mexico every year
Barbados of the 1960s was a low-income
country highly dependent on sugar
exports yet to make the transition to a
relatively High income tourism country
independent from the British Empire the
potential of a burgeoning space launch
industry on the tiny Island was met with
enthusiasm by the country's government
striking a deal with McGill University
to meet its objectives project harp
needed an extremely powerful gun with a
delicate control over the explosive
power pushing the payload towards space
projectile design is the first area of
concern this graph shows the
relationship between shot weight and
muzzle velocity for the harp gun system
a lower Mass projectile will have a
higher muzzle velocity we need to
balance this with the ballistic
coefficient which is a measure of the
projectile's ability to resist air
resistance and maintain its velocity
found by dividing the mass of the
projectile by the dry coefficient
multiplied by the cross-sectional area
creating a narrow and dense projectile
essentially a dirt can maximize
ballistic coefficient this is why
project tarap utilized Sabo rounds a
saboted round is much narrower than the
gun barrel allowing it to minimize its
cross-section and maximize its ballistic
coefficient however we need a method of
creating a seal with the gun barrel
allowing the propellant's pressure to
act on the projectile there are several
design options for sabos but as we saw
projectile waste affects muzzle velocity
and these sabos increase the effect of
projectile weight despite Falling Away
upon leaving the barrel so it's vital
that we keep these plates as light as
possible
the main body of the posher plate is
made from lightweight aluminum but
aluminum is quite soft and the base of
the missile has a low area with the
immense pressure pushing on the fins
From Below they can begin to sink into
the aluminum to counteract this a high
strength steel insert is often added for
the projectile to sit upon we then need
some method of keeping the projectile
aligned in the barrel this often was as
simple as placing laminated plywood
cutouts between each fin finally we need
a soft material that won't scratch the
barrel to form a Tight Seal between the
Sabo and the barrel for this project
harp used polyethylene the altitude
reached is ultimately decided by the
velocity of the projectile exiting the
barrel the muzzle velocity from here
pressure from the gun's Barrel will no
longer be acting on the projectile an
atmospheric drag will begin to sap away
the kinetic energy imbued to it using
gunpowder as an energy source is a
challenge produce too much energy too
quickly and the barrel of the gun will
be over pressured at best this damages
the gun at worst it creates a bar
key to ballistic performance is this
graph the gun pressure Distribution on
the x-axis we have the distance from the
breech face and on the y-axis we have
pressure which may look something like
this over the centuries there have been
many ways of assessing the pressure
along points in the barrel with some of
the earliest being simple copper or lead
plates placed inside the gun barrel that
will deform according to the pressure
they experienced but the piezoelectric
Crystal sensor revolutionized the
science this sensor which uses a
piezoelectric Crystal could measure a
variant pressure over time providing a
real-time measurement of pressure not a
single maximum pressure point provided
by a metal deformation place
piezoelectric means a material typically
a crystal generates an electric current
when mechanical stress is applied a
current which can be measured to
generate a pressure reading these
sensors can be placed at the bottom of
rounds to develop optimized pressure
gradients allowing scientists to test
new methods with the ultimate goal of
maximizing the area under this curve
that's the total energy released without
exceeding the maximum pressure the gun
can handle project therapy used some
clever methods to achieve this first the
most obvious extending the length of the
barrel the longer the barrel the more
time the pressure has to act on the
projectile however as the propellant
continues to burn and the volume behind
the projectile increases the pressure
behind it continually diminishes
eventually aerodynamic drag and friction
between the projectile and the barrel
will equal the pressure behind the
projectile and no further gains in
velocity are possible so we need to
figure out what the optimal barrel
length for a given charge and projectile
will be next we need to maximize the
energy released from our propellant to
increase muzzle velocity project harp
needed black powder a lot of black
powder they used huge 50 kilogram
propellant packs that were rammed into
the barrel with a hydraulic press behind
the projectile stacked directly on top
of each other each having ignition
charges sewn into the back of each bag
facing the primer these ignition charges
only worked when the initial flame front
from the primer reached them with
sufficient temperatures
finally a large air gap between the
final bag and the Sabo base was included
but tests using this configuration did
not end as expected
this is a typical pressure time diagram
output by the sensors inside the barrel
for these early tests the peak pressure
here is a lot higher than the scientists
predicted and the muzzle velocity came
in lower than expected Clues to the
cause began to emerge upon inspecting
the polyethylene disc from the bottom of
the Sabo grains of unburnt black powder
were lodged in the soft white plastic
unburnt black powder means the total
energy potential of the propellant was
not realized but also indicates a larger
problem this is what was theorized to be
happening the primer ignites the first
black powder bag creating a pressure
front which forces the column of bags
towards the Sabo base while Hot Gas
flows around the edges towards the
projectile the flame front begins
marching forward at a slower rate than
the pressure front while the pressure
front compresses the bags preventing
further gas from flowing around them
impeding the flame front further the
column impacts the Sabo at high speed
the force of this impact was at times
large enough to cause damage to the Sabo
and projectile at this time the flame
front catches up and a high pressure
region is created in the compacted Zone
which travels backwards towards the
breach wasting precious kinetic energy
testing new methods with the only 16
inch 120 foot long gun in the world was
not feasible so interior ballistic tests
were performed with this a massive
instrumented Barrel on Rails that
recoils backwards down the rails with
each firing allowing the researchers to
develop new ignition methods in relative
safety although it was called the harp
flyer because it would frequently fly
off its mountains when tests
over-pressured it
a solution to the black powder bags
racing ahead of the flame front was
devised by placing light wooden spacers
between the backs these spacers would
prevent the movement of the backs but
also help the bags further along the
barrel to ignite as the hot gas could
reach them in the air gaps provided by
the spacers
using the harp flyer ballistic
performance graphs comparing the two
methods were created and they looked
like this with Peak pressure lowering
and the area underneath the curve being
larger for the spaced charges this did
not solve the issue completely and the
final configuration included
electrically fired squibs to
simultaneously fire all bags together
the projectiles themselves took many
forms with different payloads and
Designs one fascinating payload came in
the form of tri-metal aluminum or TMA a
liquid chemical that was loaded into the
inside of the missile but this was not a
propellant the liquid was pumped from
the rocket with a piston driven by
compressed nitrogen gas triggered by a
timer once outside the rocket the TMA
began to react with oxygen in the ozone
layer forming a luminescent tracer Cloud
a cloud that glowed in the dark allowing
ground observers to easily see it this
tracer was used to analyze wind shear in
the upper atmosphere vital data in an
era of intense aerodynamic development
project Harry provided a cheap and
reliable method of studying the upper
atmosphere when compared to sounding
rocket Alternatives the US Army's
funding was tied to this objective but
the Canadian leadership of project harp
had loftier Ambitions centered around a
massive gun capable of launching
satellites to space a gun with twice the
bore diameter of project Arab's largest
gun at 32 inches with thick solid steel
walls to withstand the expected increase
in Barrel pressure however the real
challenge would be in the development of
a multi-stage high mass fraction rocket
system capable of firing from the gun
and accurately placing a satellite into
orbis
the martlet 4 was designed for this
purpose a full bore design removing the
need for a Sabo only the polyethylene
disc was included to protect the bottom
of the rocket from the hot gas inside
the barrel this is a massive challenge
during launch the rocket would be under
extreme compressive load this would
cause the rocket to bulge outwards
creating friction with the barrel on one
test the fiberglass rocket actually got
stuck inside the barrel and the gun
pressure burst through the middle of the
rocket blowing the internals of the
rocket out of the muzzle like a giant
Buckshot Cannon developing the system
required numerous tests with inert
propellant stand-ins longitudinal
Stripes were painted onto test
projectiles to examine friction wear
after each shot for these tests the gun
was moved to an ice and snow-covered
Lake north of McGill's Montreal campus
here they could fire the projectiles in
a horizontal position landing on the
snow and ice and slowly decelerating to
be recovered by the researchers for
analysis
another design the martlet 3C was
designed to be slightly smaller than the
gunbore and the space between the barrel
and the rocket casing was filled with a
dense fluid that would travel with the
rocket in bore and prevent friction on
the rocket casing it was ultimately
decided after testing that a full bore
rocket made from fiberglass with a
Teflon coating was the best option when
it came time to test active propellant
the propellant grain layers were
laminated together with a hydraulic
press around a stair-shaped mandrel when
dried an inhibitor coating was applied
and the end casings including the nozzle
were fitted and then the fiber casing
was simply wrapped around the solid
propellant and cured this was an
extremely cheap method of construction
structural issues were assessed with
this method and when completed flip out
stabilization fins were Incorporated and
the single stage martlet 3E was born
capable of placing a 25 kilogram payload
to an apogee of 450 kilometers above the
orbiting altitude of the ISS how however
this was not orbit without the necessary
horizontal velocity these payloads would
simply fall back to Earth to achieve
orbit a multi-stage system was needed
the martlet 4. however scaling a system
like this up would be extremely
difficult G hardening guidance and
control systems were needed feeding into
a central computer that controlled cold
gas thrusters High acceleration tests
proved these systems were capable of
surviving up to 5000 G's well above the
launch acceleration the staging would
necessitate gradual decreasing of
diameter and so the previous method of
fluid support was Revisited this
optimized staging method was proving
difficult to develop with the time
pressure on the program The Joint U.S
Canadian program was time limited to
three years and the engineers at project
harp pursued unguided multi-stage
Rockets based on earlier sabotage
systems ultimately the program ended on
June 30th 1967 before its Ambitions
could be realized managing the
bureaucracy between three institutions a
university a government and a military
proved too difficult each having their
own priorities leaving the chief
engineer behind project term Gerald ball
lost in the Wind
seeking a new Patron for his expertise
he wrote his own demise Beginning by
selling and smuggling weapons to the
South African government ignoring a
United Nations arms embargo and earning
himself six months in U.S prison upon
release he continued selling arms to the
South African government and got caught
and fined again eventually moving to
Brussels to ply his trade there in 1981
he was approached by the Iraqi
government led by the now Infamous
Saddam Hussein with the 25 million
dollar paycheck Paul took the knowledge
he gained during project harp to Iraq to
begin a new project project Babylon a
project with the ultimate goal of
building an artillery weapon capable of
firing from Iraq into Israel and Iran a
hare brain scheme that was proven to be
completely tactically useless during
World War II and would be even less
effective in the era of guided missiles
bull was supposedly aware of how
ineffective this would be as a weapon
and used that as justification to
continue his research but the Israeli
government didn't see things that way
and Mr Bull was assassinated while he
placed the key into the door of his
Brussels home he was found by police
lying on the ground with a briefcase
containing twenty thousand dollars
inside other projects like project sharp
and even bigger light gas-powered gun
was tested in California in the 90s no
projectile can exceed the velocity of
the propellant pushing it and project
sharp realized this and began using
lightweight hydrogen gas instead capable
of achieving a muzzle velocity of seven
kilometers per second but the estimated
1 billion dollars in funding needed to
scale it up never arrived and the system
ultimately was used to test sub-scale
Hypersonic scramjet designs
today spin launch is attempting to pick
up where project harp left off using a
completely different form of kinetic
launch system to replace large expensive
first stage Rockets
the engineering Behind these problems
need work but the physics absolutely
check out and you can test that for
yourself with a real engineering course
on brilliant that deep dives into the
science behind Rockets including orbits
and centripetal acceleration it's
powerful knowledge to obtain and you can
complete this Chorus for free by signing
up at brilliant.org forward slash real
engineering getting started on your
first course is completely free for the
first 30 days but the first 500 people
that sign up with our link will get 20
off brilliant's annual premium
subscription brilliant makes learning
fun and interesting with bite-sized
interactive lessons that make it easy to
jump in and out of courses so you can
learn on your own time and it's even
easier with their mobile app so you can
learn the fundamentals of computer
science on your morning commute to work
or school and when you're done with that
you can move on to more advanced
computer science courses like their
intro to neural networks brilliant
includes interactive elements to help
you quickly understand and Concepts and
test your knowledge along the way to
ensure you are understanding the
concepts you are learning brilliant
focuses on facilitating Effective
Education that will help you progress in
your learning goals whether it's
professional career advancement or just
for fun for lifelong Learners brilliant
or adding content monthly so there's
always something new to learn you can
get started for free for the first 30
days by clicking the link on screen now
and the first 500 people to do so will
guess 20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription
foreign
[Music]